[Música]
las fuerzas rusas controlan ya la mayor
parte de severodonezk según el
gobernador local quien agregó que los
ataques impiden la evacuación de civiles
de otro lado el kremlin advirtió de un
eventual choque con un tercer país en
medio del suministro de armas al crack
y en medio de una intensa jornada de
protestas en chile el presidente gabriel
police presentó la primera cuenta
pública sobre su gobierno en un discurso
con alto contenido social el mandatario
anunció la esperada reforma a las
pensiones y un plan para prohibir la
tenencia de hadas
reino unido- ultima detalles para el
inicio de las celebraciones por el
jubileo de platino de la reina isabel 2a
quien cumple 70 años en el trono se
espera que el momento cumbre sea el
esperado saludo de esta monarca desde el
balcón en el palacio de buckingham
acompañada de sus familiares aunque
habrá ausencias
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos con noticias de la
guerra en ucrania el gobernador de la
provincia de lugansk anunció que las
fuerzas rusas controlan la mayor parte
de la ciudad de severodonezk pero que
aún no la han rodeado el mandatario
local agregó que los ataques del
ejército del kremlin que además se
extienden por toda la región del donbass
están dificultando no sólo la evacuación
de civiles que se esconden en una planta
química sino también la entrega de ayuda
humanitaria
la situación actual no ha cambiado el
70% permanece bajo control ruso bajo el
control del ejército ruso alrededor del
10 o 15 por ciento es una especie es una
gris y el resto del territorio está en
manos de nuestros defensores
de otro lado revive la escalada de
tensiones entre rusia y eeuu el ministro
de exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov
advirtió de un eventual choque con
occidente luego de que eeuu anunciara
que planea proporcionar a ucrania
sistemas avanzados de misiles que
podrían atacar objetivos de largo
alcance lo que trae preocupaciones de
que puedan golpear territorio sin
embargo washington dijo que recibió
garantías de kiev de que sólo usará los
misiles para defenderse
vamos ahora eeuu porque este miércoles
se registró un nuevo tiroteo en un
edificio médico de tulsa oklahoma
dejando unas 4 personas muertas se cree
que el atacante que según informes
preliminares llevaba un rifle y una
pistola también murió según indicó la
policía
la tragedia se reporta después de dos
tiroteos mortales registrados en menos
de un mes en eeuu el primero en buffalo
nueva york con diez víctimas mortales y
luego en balde con 21 fallecidos
en el salvador el presidente en allí
porque le cumplió este miércoles tres
años en el poder durante los años de
gobierno el mandatario ha enfrentado
críticas de organizaciones de derechos
humanos y de la comunidad internacional
en medio de su lucha contra las
pandillas y también por una serie de
acciones y decisiones como por ejemplo
destituir a magistrados de la sala
constitucional de la corte suprema de
justicia para nombrar jueces leales a él
o por ejemplo la de optar el bitcoin
como o adoptar el bitcoin como moneda
legal sin embargo la imagen de bukele
cuenta con una alta aprobación en el
país
y ante un congreso con aforo limitado el
presidente de chile gabriel boric dio su
primera cuenta pública se trata de un
tradicional discurso en el que el
mandatario chileno da a conocer cómo
está el estado administrativo y político
del país el mandatario dividió su
discurso en cinco ejes principales en
los que intentó explicar el rumbo y
metas de su gobierno
poco más de dos meses después de jurar
el cargo el presidente gabriel boric se
dirigió a la nación por primera vez hace
solo tres años tres años
las muertes en el marco del estallido
social
nos obligaron a una tarea muy dura
de que en nuestro país hay ocasiones en
que protestar se termina pagando con la
vida y eso no lo podemos seguir
permitiendo verdad justicia memoria
reparación y no repetición entre sus
promesas mejorar la carta magna y
apostar por políticas sociales educación
combatir la brecha de género y una
pensión de vejez digna y asegurada con
especial hincapié en su propuesta de
seguridad para la prohibición total de
tenencia de armas y para reformar los
carabineros polémico cuerpo policial
acusado de violaciones de derechos
humanos y cómplice de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet tenemos la convicción
de que reformar carabineros es mejorar
la seguridad del país la reforma es por
la institución y no en contra de una
jornada empañada por la sombra del
descontento en forma de protestas y es
que en lo poco que lleva de mandato el
izquierdista ha visto una fuerte caída
de su popularidad en medio de la crisis
de seguridad en el país y la creciente
inflación motivos por los que los
estudiantes que una vez lo respaldaron
ahora le dan la espalda si bien uno
entiende que los cambios son
graduales que son paulatinos igual se
prometía demasiado y con esa con ese
ímpetu en que prometen también una
espera una inmediatez aunque no todos
piensan igual creo que hay que darle la
oportunidad y tiempo para poder hacer
las cosas el mandatario ha prometido
solucionar el problema de tierras con
los mapuches en las regiones del sur del
país algo que junto a la aprobación o
rechazo de la constituyente será
decisivo para su gobierno
el juicio de difamación entre amber
heard y johnny depp llegó a su fin luego
de seis intensas semanas en las que las
dos partes pudieron exponer sus
testimonios en el condado de fairfax en
virginia el jurado determinó que ambos
eran culpables de difamación aunque la
suma de dinero que la actriz deberá
pagar al actor por daños y prejuicios es
más alta que la que tendrá que
desembolsar adriana villacorta nos
amplia
un triunfo de la verdad y de la justicia
así es como los abogados de johnny depp
calificaron la decisión de un jurado de
virginia que determinó que la actriz
amber hearn difamó a su ex esposo al
acusarlo de violencia doméstica dando
así fin a un mediático juicio que duró
seis semanas
nuestro sistema judicial se basa en el
derecho de cada persona que se escuche
de su caso y nos sentimos honrados
verdaderamente honrados de ayudar al
señor de para garantizar que su caso se
considerara de forma justa a lo largo
del juicio también estamos muy
satisfechos de que el juicio haya
resonado para tantas personas del
público que valoran la verdad y la
justicia
ahora que el jurado ha llegado a su
veredicto concluyente es hora de pasar
página y mirar al futuro
[Música]
pero antes de que este capítulo pase al
olvido el jurado ordenó también a johnny
depp desembolsar dos millones de dólares
a la actriz por daños y prejuicios
mientras que tendrá que pagarle al
protagonista de piratas del caribe más
de 10 millones de dólares un veredicto
que la actriz consideró como proceso
para los derechos de las mujeres estoy
aún más decepcionada por lo que este
veredicto significa para las mujeres es
un retroceso retrocede a una época en la
que una mujer que hablaba y denunciaba
podría ser avergonzada y humillada
públicamente
retrocede a la idea de que la violencia
contra las mujeres debe ser tomada en
serio
demandó a heart por 50 millones de
dólares y argumentó que lo difamó cuando
se llamó a sí misma una figura pública
que representa el abuso doméstico en un
artículo de opinión publicado en the
washington post en el que no nombraba a
depp pero que la actor asegura le trajo
graves consecuencias
la actriz reaccionó poniendo una
contrademanda a su exmarido por un valor
de 100 millones de dólares en el juicio
que fue televisado y seguido por
millones de personas alrededor del mundo
tanto depp como heart revelaron detalles
íntimos de su vida en pareja y ambos
detallaron situaciones de abuso durante
su relación reino unido está listo para
celebrar la fiesta de su monarca el
jubileo de platino de la reina isabel
segunda se festejará durante cuatro días
desde este jueves con eventos especiales
en todo el país se espera que millones
de personas asistan a los eventos que
celebran los 70 años de la monarca en el
trono pero este año las polémicas no
estarán ausentes
es una fiesta digna de una reina y antes
del inicio de las celebraciones que
marquen el jubileo del platino de la
reina isabel sus admiradores buscan los
mejores lugares frente al palacio
buckingham
es un modelo para mujeres y hombres
siempre fue un sueño asistir al
tradicional desfile y ver a la reina el
desfile matutino shuping de calders
seria uno de los momentos cumbres del
jubileo y fue el propio príncipe william
quien dirigió los sencillos hasta el
gran día más de 1.500 soldados
participarán en el desfile un
espectáculo tradicional de pompa y
esplendor que se celebra todos los años
para el cumpleaños de la monarca después
a mediodía habrá salvas de cañón en todo
el país la torre de londres disparará
120 rondas
en la tarde la reina junto a los
miembros de la familia real saldrá al
balcón del palacio de bukingham para
observar el desfile aéreo de 6 minutos
pero este año no estará el príncipe
andrew después de que el hijo de la
monarca renunciara a sus deberes reales
solo los miembros de la realeza que
trabajan en la monarquía están
permitidos en el balcón significa
también que el príncipe herbie y su
esposa megan marcotte no estarán para de
terminar esta jornada habrá un
espectáculo de luces con miles de
balizas encendidas en todo reino unido-
y en decenas de capitales de la
commonwealth pero las celebraciones
continuarán con un concierto en el
palacio de bukingham el sábado y se
espera que millones de personas
participen en las fiestas callejeras del
jubileo el domingo
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]